bonjour je suis dominique de saint marc
donc je suis l'auteur de max et lili cd
livres tout petit mais qui sont partout
et sont allés dans les écoles dans les
bibliothèques et j'espère que vous avez
tous lu quand vous étiez petit voilà
donc il faut que je parle les émotions
et là je vous dois une confidence pour
commencer parce qu'en fait j'ai un
problème c'est que je joue je pense que
ça vient de mon enfance mais j'essaierai
de vous expliquer un peu plus tard j'ai
un problème c'est que je ne supporte pas
de voir un enfant souffrir donc par
exemple je vous donne un exemple l'autre
jour j'étais dans une dans la rue et il
y avait des parents qui arrivait d'un
voyage en voiture ils étaient une petite
fille qui hurlait et qui disait mais
j'aime à l'intel gma la tête et criait
et je me suis approché et puis j'ai le
père lui disait mais non ça doit être tu
as regardé trop de dessin animé c'est ta
faute tout ça et je me suis approché
j'ai dit au père à côté c'est pas
possible
une petite fille ne dit pas quelle est
ma tête si si la femme à la tête elle
est peut-être malades votre petite fille
du coup il m'a regardé avec un oeil noir
et ensuite j'étais vers la mer et puis
la mer pareil qui avaient des valises un
bébé dans les bras elle m'a dit helm a
balayé de bras enfin voilà donc c'était
juste pour vous dire que j'ai cette
sorte d'obsession de 2,2 de ne pas
vouloir voir d'aider des enfants
souffrir et c'est vrai que quand j'étais
journaliste à un strapping pendant 16
ans ça va beaucoup calmé parce que j'ai
pu
vous pouvez enfin j'ai pu écrire des
états devant le dessiner pour les
enfants sur les sur les émotions sur les
relations parents enfants
je me suis senti la maman de 2 200 mille
enfants pratiquement donc et puis j'ai
beaucoup appris et j'ai beaucoup appris
astrapi d'abord pour mes enfants parce
qu'il était petit à l'époque et et puis
j'ai appris
vous savez c'était la génération dolto
donc j'ai appris que les enfants étaient
pas des petits singes qu'on voulait
dresser que c'était pas des moitiés de
personnes que qu'il fallait écouter
leurs émotions qu'il fallait les
respecter mais dolto parler au cid des
limites et de l'autorité qui étaient
nécessaires à l'enfant parce qu'on ne
conduit pas souvent et puis on apprenait
aussi que si on
si on nous réfrénait l'émotion des
enfants ça pouvait aider conflit créé
des jalousies même qui pourrait se
retrouver à l'âge adulte entre frères et
soeurs je sais pas si vous avez connu
des héritages difficile et souvent c'est
des jalousies qui viennent de l'enfance
donc il faut s'en occuper à mon avis
quand on est petit je pense que c'est
mieux quand même
et voilà donc là c'était astra pis ça
m'a fait beaucoup de bien ça m'a calmé
et et quand j'ai eu l'idée de créer max
et lili j'ai trouvé christian et pascal
ghanima comme éditeur j'ai tout de suite
voulu
c'était une collection pour parler des
émotions des enfants et j'ai tout de
suite voulu que ce soit une histoire de
frères et soeurs est donc là vous avez
quand on écrit un scénario on invente
[Musique]
l'histoire les scènes les dialogues mais
surtout est donc là il fallait que je
trouve un dessinateur donc j'ai demandé
à serge bloch dont j'aimais beaucoup le
dessin
si vous voulez m'accompagner dans cette
aventure et l'âge et il a accepté et et
c'est vrai que je le trouve toujours
aussi génial depuis 25 ans j'adore son
dessin est aussi génial mon mari qui m'a
beaucoup soutenu dans cette aventure et
qui m'a aidé pour vous si souvent pour
les scénarios voilà donc je suis un
auteur heureux malgré toutes ces
émotions et et j'en suis à mon sens 15e
max et les voilà donc la caisse qui est
je pourrais vous dire sur max et lili
qui ce que vous ne saviez pas déjà et
j'espère alors je vous montre les j'ai
fait une petite sélection des max et
lili des émotions d'un max et lili et
j'en ai traité beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup depuis 25 ans donc voilà j'ai
choisi lily se dispute avec son frère
parce que les parents dit souvent
arrêtez de vous battre
ça suffit mais en fait derrière ce qu'on
croit être un jeu et souvent se cache
une lutte sans merci entre les entre les
frères et les soeurs pour avoir l'amour
des parents ou pour trouver sa place
dans la famille et il ya des enfants qui
n'ont pas de places qui sont peut-être
qu'ils ressemblent pas parent ou qui
ressemble à la grand mère qu'on déteste
enfin bon il ya des enfants qui trouvent
pas leur place
et donc voilà je me suis dit que c'était
très important de que si on
si on trouvait les mots pour comprendre
la souffrance de l'autre même les
enfants étaient moins en rivalité moins
d'ennemis et il pouvait plus et devenir
des alliés s'ils se comprenait en fait
il comprenait que l'autre souffraient
aussi le second c'est la timidité tous
les beaucoup d'enfants sont timides je
leur dis toujours que c'est une force la
timidité parce qu'on observe on a le
temps d'observer les autres tandis que
les autres se lancent dans la dans les
paroles et ici ils nous observent - fin
souvent et donc là ce qui est
intéressant c'est la reconnaissance de
l'émotion je passe en premier par ça il
faut d'abord reconnaître l'émotion
ensuite en parler et ensuite trouver des
solutions voilà donc là il ya la
reconnaissance de la maman et du papa là
c'est c'est une conversation dans leur
lit j'ai imaginé beaucoup de deux
séquences dans max et lili où ils sont
en train de parler dans leur lit
toujours parce que j'aime la relation
frères soeurs et que je trouve que c'est
une grande chance de pouvoir partager
des émotions et des expériences de la
journée ou opposées ont posé des
questions savoir un peu ce que ce que
l'autre en pensée tous à lasser les
parents qui se disputent qu'ils
entendent à travers les cloisons la
cloison dons qui sont affolés mais cette
relation frères et soeurs et ses
conversations sont souvent
dans max et lili là c'est la suite des
disputes mais heureusement c'est divorce
et et là c'est les parents nous aurait
dit wolf zaho et vient de dire à son
père que si il aimait plus amers ils
pouvaient plus les mais elle voilà donc
c'est l'éternelle difficulté de du
divorce est là elle ose dire que elle
veut aimer ses deux parents donc avoir
la permission et de démêler 2 et qui ait
pas de conflit loyauté pour aimer l'un
plus que l'autre celui avec qui on vit
et tout ça donc je trouve ça très
important le divorce
c'est une des grandes maltraitance aux
enfants de notre époque et j'ai fait
trois livres de max et livia dessus
parce que je trouve que c'est ça peut on
s'en sort quand même on n'en meurt pas
mais je pense qu'il faut en parler quand
même il faut vraiment enfin exprimer les
émotions aux enfants au moment où ils
apprennent au moment après aux moyennes
famille rocco qui se recompose chossat
capitale alors là je vous ai choisi
cette image parce que j'avais imaginé
c'est alex est handicapé et j'avais
imaginé que on pouvait que max pouvait
se mettre dans la dans le fauteuil
électrique de d'alex pour justement
comprendre ce que alex ressentait pour
avoir de l'empathie pour pourvoir ce
qu'ils enduraient pas se sentir avec ce
qu'ils enduraient et puis entendre les
mots d'alex qui sont très forts et qui
sont assez tabou en fait parce que il
dit à sa mère bientôt tu pourras plus me
porter je te donne mal au dos
peut-être que j'aurais pas dû n'être
j'avais hésité à faire cette phrase
parce que c'est quand même effrayant
qu'un enfant puisse dire ça mais en même
temps je me suis dit que voilà c'est
souvent je dis des choses que les
enfants pensent et je vais un petit peu
plus loin peut-être mais comme c'est un
peu drôle et qu' il ya des saints et
tout ça qu'en fait ça passe ça choque
pas en général les vaccine ne choque pas
les enfants faut pas de cauchemars donc
[Rires]
énorme c'est mon objectif c'est
d'arriver à dire le maximum de choses là
maximum de dos le raffinement dans la
pensée et en même temps que l'enfant
n'en fait pas un cauchemar
traumatisée à vie alors là c'est un
sujet très important aussi de pour
l'enfance et le sentiment de rejet la
maxe pense qu'ils ont tous laissé tomber
il n'est pas invité à un anniversaire
c'est un drame pour certains enfants ne
pas être imputée à une adversaire donc
ça je pense que c'est une fondamentale
pour les enfants d'arriver à exprimer
ses émotions là et trouver des solutions
à trouver d'autres enfants d'autres
groupes
ça c'est dans les livres j'essaie de
trouver d'autres solutions
là j'aime beaucoup cette image parce que
c'est cet homme c'est une explication
entre père et fils max un malentendu en
fait
et j'aime bien ces malentendus parce
qu'on croit quand on veut quelque chose
pour l'autre en fait l'autre le
comprends pas du tout comme ça devrait
être donc la maxe avoue que et il est
très déçu par la déception de son père
parce que il ne pense qu'à une chose
c'est à lui faire plaisir à son père et
avec le stress de l'école je veux dire
c'est assez difficile de faire plaisir
aux parents et de se faire plaisir à soi
même quand on est un enfant qui a envie
de jouer
car oui j'aime beaucoup cette relation
parce que c'est une relation père fils
qui se dit les choses et qui qui parle
d'un malentendu
alors cette réussite et images les
inventer pour pour faire rire les
parents un peu pour les déculpabiliser
les pauvres parce qu'ils sont tellement
stressé parce qu'il faut que les enfants
réussissent et que là ils ont réussi à
calmer les lits qui est enfin d'or dans
leur lit et qui être tout à fait
paisible mais par contre eux sont
totalement stressé par le le contrôle de
lilith et le lendemain et donc ce qui
est drôle ce qu'ils disent les profs
devraient quand même s'en rendre compte
de l' angoisse des enfants alors que
c'est leur propre angoisse dont il parle
voilà donc je suis l'ami des parents
dans la collection est franchement
j'essaye de jeu juste je dis souvent que
je suis que j'écris des livres pour les
parents et pour les enfants c'est à dire
que c'est souvent d'ailleurs les parents
lisent beaucoup les max et lili ça leur
donne des idées puissent aller ça les
calme aussi salée ça les rend plus y
rigole donc donc donc c'est bon l'humour
enlève le stress ça ça permet de dire
les choses en même temps de dette moins
stressés et là c'est la dernière que
j'ai choisi parce que je trouve que les
grands-parents sont extrêmement
importantes dans ces périodes de deux
divorces et et donc les parents les
grands parents ils n'ont pas la pression
de la colle ils ont été un peu moins
active quoique et donc ils ont plus de
calme plus de tendresse de ils sont à
l'autre bout de la vie donc quand même
il sait aussi une dimension
existentielle [ __ ] à 100 permet aux
enfants de se projeter un avenir et donc
et puis je voulais aussi dire que le
stress c'était contagieux comme la
confiance en soi c'est l'idée que je
trouve très importante
d'ailleurs ça a été vérifié par les
cellules miroir pour les bébés qui
peut-on quand l'apparence ouvrit le bébé
fait comme s'il se voyait
et donc voilà donc les grands parents
c'est ça peut apporter ce set ce
bien-être en tête voilà là je voudrais
rester sur les grands parents parce que
je vous ai dit que j'allais vous
parlerez parler de la vraie origine de
max et lili mais en fait la vraie
origine de max et lili c'est la
rencontre entre mon histoire personnelle
qui était qui a été assez difficile
quand même dans une famille assez
difficile et le fait que l'on m'ait
donné l'occasion de décrire des bandes
dessinées donc c'est on est toujours que
c'est souvent la rencontre de deux
choses qui fait que qu'une oeuvre
quelque chose marche en fait et touche
le grand nombre de gens et là c'est vrai
que les grands parents j'ai peut-être
manqué de grands parents réalité parce
que mes grands-parents maternels sont
sombres très jeune
écrasés dans leur voiture par un train
et donc ma mère j'ai été élevé par une
mère orphelines et c'est pas rien
d'avoir une mère qui n'a pas de parents
quand on est un enfant et puis surtout
dans des conditions aussi dramatique
quand même et et puis il ya eu un autre
truc c'est que mon frère aîné a été
enfin il était là mal vécu le divorce de
nos parents il a été
harcelé au lycée il n'était pas bien
dans sa peau finalement il est tombé
dans la schizophrénie dans la dépression
et à 33 ans il s'est suicidé il si tu es
un dimanche soir pour parce qu'il
voulait pas retourner à l'hôpital le
lendemain
voilà donc c'est vrai que ces évènements
douloureux mon nom presque
et puis ce qui est important de dire
c'est que en fait nous quand on était
enfants on était cinq enfants
on comprenait rien est la maladie de mon
de notre frère on on pensait qu'il était
méchant c'est que il était agressif on
se moquait de lui on me traite de tous
les noms
et en fait mais pas renvoyer pas grand
chose non plus donc c'est pour ça mon
obsession en fait à faire comprendre ce
qui se passe dans la tête des enfants
vient sûrement de la voilà tout
simplement
et aussi à transformer le tristan drôle
ce que j'aime bien les tout drôle quand
même et élus - est très très important
en drôle moi mon bon gars ou en bien
donc voilà je vous ai à peu raconté le
[Musique]
vérité la vérité sur max et lili et je
suis très heureuse en tout cas que max
et lili aide les enfants à gérer leurs
émotions et c'est vrai que le jour les
jours où je suis très optimiste je me
dis que c'est livre de max et lili
peuvent aussi servir aux enfants à
éduquer leurs parents on sait jamais
voilà merci
[Applaudissements]